.
Ich würde wirklich gern
draussen im Erker gebären.
Wenn ich schon nicht
unter einem Baum gebären kann,
dann wenigstens zwischen den vielen
von Stefan gepflanzten Samen
und Kernen.
Tut das ein bisschen weh?
Das ist der Muttermund.- Ja.
Er ist noch etwa ...
... 1-2 cm Portio.
- Ja.
Ich mag sie lieber, wenn sie
nicht schwanger ist.- Wieso?
Du bist schön und es ist schön, dass
du schwanger bist, aber du bist ...
* Die Hebamme und Stefan lachen. *
Ich hörte,
ich sei etwas anstrengend.
Oder sind es alle anderen?
* Lachen *
* Stöhnen *
Oh, Baby. Baby!
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Hallo.
* Ein Kleinkind plappert. *
Hebamme Karin Künzle auf Hausbesuch
bei der jungen Familie
von Rebecca und Stefan.
Hallo.
* Ein Glöckchen klingelt. *
Das ist aber ein toller Empfang.
Hallo, Jeshua.
Karin Künzle
kennt die vierköpfige Familie -
Rebecca mit dem jüngsten Sohn Arun
und Stefan mit Jeshua -
schon von der letzten Geburt.
Der dreijährige Jeshua ist im Spital
zur Welt gekommen, Arun zu Hause.
Sie haben schon richtige Löckchen.
Super, schau mal.
- (Jeshua) Es hängt am Glöckchen.
Wirklich?
Ist das Glöckchen stark genug?
Weil die Mutter
einmal eine Fehlgeburt hatte,
ist die ganze Familie nervös,
ob es dieses Mal klappt,
ob es dem Kind gut geht.
Möchtest du mithelfen?
Du kannst hier ziehen.
Kräftig, kräftig.
Oh, du musst nochmals etwas ziehen.
Gut, jetzt musst du loslassen.
Schau, jetzt messen wir Mamas Bauch.
Laut Berechnung ist Rebecca in
der zwölften Schwangerschaftswoche.
Nun schaue ich,
wo die Gebärmutter ist.
Hast du sie mal ertastet?
- Ich versuchte es.
Hier, schau.
- Wirklich?
Ja.
Oh, Gott.
- Jetzt höre ich dich ab.
Sie ist schon so gross.
Das ist das schönste Gefühl.
Ich dachte,
ich würde mir nur einbilden,
dass ich sie schon
so weit oben spüre.
Du hattest Angst,
dass da gar kein Baby ist.
Ja, ich dachte, da sei nichts.
Die Gewissheit, dass ein Baby lebt
und wächst, ist eine Erleichterung.
1 % der Babys in der Schweiz
kommen zu Hause auf die Welt.
* Rauschen *
Es dauert manchmal eine Weile.
In dieser Schwangerschaftswoche
ist es nicht so einfach.
* Leise Herztöne *
Ja, Baby, zeig dich.
* Arun plappert. *
Es kommt nicht raus.
* Herztöne *
Das ist das Herz des Kindes.
Oh, Rebecca.
Wir sind glücklich.
* Sie lacht. *
* Herztöne *
Die Freude ist gross.
Dieses Mal soll es klappen.
Der Geburtstermin ist Mitte Oktober.
Siehst du das Gel?
Du kannst alles wegwischen.
Nun bin ich total erleichtert.
Es ist ein gutes Gefühl, zu wissen,
dass es noch da ist.
Ich muss nicht unbedingt
die Herztöne hören
oder ein Ultraschallbild sehen,
aber es ist schön,
zu wissen, dass es da ist.
Bis der Zeiger hier oben ist.
Ich helfe dir.
Der dreijährige Jeshua
hilft tatkräftig mit.
Stopp. Jetzt höre ich es mir an.
Danach muss der Zeiger
wieder unten sein.
Karin Künzle arbeitet
seit fast zehn Jahren als Hebamme,
hat 250 Geburten begleitet,
gut 100 davon waren Hausgeburten.
Zu den Familien
pflegt sie ein enges Verhältnis.
Es ist natürlich schön,
dass ich bereits
eine Beziehung zu Karin habe.
Sie begleitete uns bereits,
als ich mit Arun schwanger war.
Die Tatsache, dass die Kinder dabei
sein können, macht es einfacher.
Es ist einfach ...
... eine schönere Atmosphäre.
Wenn es mit dem Kind
nichts geworden wäre,
wäre ich bereits
an einem Ort gewesen,
an dem ich mich wohlfühle und wo ich
von lieben Menschen umgeben bin.
Dann hätte ich nicht aus der Stadt
oder aus einer kalten Arztpraxis
nach Hause fahren müssen.
Bei Jeshuas Geburt
waren wir im Spital.
Dort wurde in vielerlei Hinsicht
nicht so gehandelt,
wie wir es uns gewünscht hätten.
Sie schickten mich u.a. nach Hause.
Sie sagten:
"Kommen Sie gegen 9 Uhr wieder."
Als ich um 9 Uhr wiederkam,
war das Kind schon seit Stunden da
und niemand hatte es aufgefangen.
Tja ...
Uns gefielen einige Dinge nicht.
Arun wurde zu Hause geboren.
Das war viel schöner.
Die Betreuung durch die Hebamme
ist viel mehr wert
und zudem sogar günstiger
als das Spital.
Rebecca stillt
den 16 Monate alten Arun noch immer.
Er braucht sehr viel Zuwendung,
denn er leidet
an einer Darmerkrankung.
Durch die Schwangerschaft stösst du
noch stärker an deine Grenzen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Nun macht mich die Schwangerschaft
nicht mehr ganz so müde,
aber ich habe schon wenig Energie.
Um die Belastung für
die schwangere Mutter zu verkleinern,
steht das Abstillen zur Diskussion.
Wie schwer warst du anfangs?
Ich stelle mich nie auf die Waage.
- Aha.
Tschüss.
* Kussgeräusche *
Tschüss, Arun.
- Danke, ich freue mich schon.
Ich freue mich auch.
Schau, wie gut man es sieht.
Ja, nun darf ich ihn zeigen.
Ich wünschte mir
schon immer Kinder und ...
Aber warum?
Es ist klar,
dass man Kinder braucht,
um sich fortzupflanzen.
Nein, ich weiss es auch nicht.
Ich wünschte mir schon
seit längerer Zeit Kinder.
Als ich Stefan begegnete,
erfuhr ich,
dass er auch Kinder möchte.
Wir verstanden uns
einfach von Anfang an gut
und es war immer
unkompliziert zwischen uns.
Ich glaube, das Wichtigste ist,
dass es unkompliziert ist,
dass man
gut miteinander befreundet ist
und dass man
am gleichen Strick zieht.
So, nun bin ich bereits
in der 21. Schwangerschaftswoche.
Heute ist der Tag
des grossen Organultraschalls.
Dabei wird untersucht, ob mit
den Organen alles in Ordnung ist,
wie die Plazenta arbeitet
und wo sie liegt.
Eigentlich mache ich mir
keine grossartigen Gedanken.
Ich bin guter Hoffnung.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Nun bin ich wieder zurück
vom Ultraschall.
Es sieht alles gut aus.
Die Ärztin schlug vor, in
etwa neun Wochen, in der 30. Woche,
nochmals einen Ultraschalltermin
zu vereinbaren,
damit wir uns wirklich sicher sein
können, dass alles okay ist.
Ich glaube,
dass das Kind gesund ist.
(Jeshua) Es badet.
- Badet es?
Ja.
Im Fruchtwasser, was?
Im Fruchtsalat.
Appenzell Ausserrhoden,
in der Nähe von Teufen.
Hier findet heute
ein Hauskonzert statt,
das Hebamme Karin Künzle
bei sich zu Hause organisiert.
Hallo. Hier muss die Bar
vorbereitet werden, verstehst du?
Kümmere dich doch zuerst um die Bar.
Dann macht es ein bisschen was her.
Freunde helfen Karin, die Wohnstube
in einen Konzertraum zu verwandeln.
Wir haben ...
Wir erwarten Full House.
Heute tritt Karins Partner Elias auf.
Darf ich das mitnehmen?
Dieses Konzert
will sie auf keinen Fall verpassen.
Später.
* Muntere Klänge *
Die grösste Schwierigkeit
bei meiner Tätigkeit
als Hebamme für Hausgeburten ist,
dass ich nicht weiss,
wann die Geburten stattfinden.
Ich kann es vielleicht eingrenzen,
aber wenn ich viele Geburten habe,
bin ich unter Umständen
permanent auf Abruf,
ausser eine Frau
gebärt früher als gedacht
und eine andere ist
noch nicht in der Pikettzeit.
D.h., ich weiss nie,
ob meine geplanten Aktivitäten
stattfinden können oder nicht.
Das löst bei mir
in vielen Situationen
einen gewissen Stress aus.
* Muntere Musik *
Das Konzert will sie geniessen,
aber Karin ist nonstop auf Abruf,
bereit für einen Einsatz,
aber auch für Fragen und Ängste
werdender Mütter.
Nur wenige Hebammen
begleiten Hausgeburten.
Die Arbeitsbelastung
und Verantwortung sind hoch.
Unter den Gästen ist Priska
mit ihrem zwei Monate alten Moritz.
Auch er ist daheim zur Welt gekommen.
Karin hat sie begleitet -
wie auch schon die Geburt
des älteren Geschwisterchens.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
* Applaus *
Ava kam in einer
total stürmischen Nacht zur Welt.
Die Geburt zu Hause
in der gewohnten Umgebung
erleben zu können ...
Karin ist
eine gute Freundin von uns.
So blieb das Ganze
im kleinen Rahmen.
Die Frauen,
die im Spital gebaren, sagen ...
... dass man irgendwie aus der
Geburtsstimmung herausgerissen wird,
wenn man seine Sachen packen
und ins Spital fahren muss.
Wenn man zu Hause bleiben kann,
gerät man in die Zauberwelt
der Geburt und bleibt dort.
Ich höre leider oft,
dass Frauen beim ersten Kind
ganz schlechte Erfahrungen
im Spital machen
und sich daher beim zweiten
eine Hausgeburt wünschen.
Sie fühlten sich z.B.
nicht ernst genommen,
erlebten sehr viel Gewalt
unter der Geburt ...
... oder konnten nicht loslassen.
Daher wollen sie sich
anders vorbereiten
oder anders begleitet werden,
damit sie mehr Vertrauen
in diesen Prozess haben.
Einige Frauen, wie z.B. Priska,
entscheiden sich schon beim
ersten Kind für eine Hausgeburt,
da sie einen anderen Bezug
zum Thema Gesundheit
und zum Geburtsprozess haben.
Was gibt es noch?
Ganz unterschiedliche Leute wollen
eine Hausgeburt. Es ist ein Gefühl.
Auch der Hebamme ist bewusst:
Eine Hausgeburt ist
nicht für alle das Richtige -
Gesundheit und Einstellung
müssen stimmen.
* Lachen *
Ich stelle mir vor,
dass ich draussen im Erker gebäre,
in der Hocke,
damit ich das Baby
gleich zu mir hochnehmen kann.
Mitte Oktober soll hier
in St. Gallen, in diesem Erker,
Rebeccas drittes Baby
auf die Welt kommen.
Mittlerweile ist Rebecca
in der 23. Schwangerschaftswoche.
Halbzeit ist vorbei.
Gut alle fünf Wochen
kommt Karin zur Kontrolle vorbei,
eine enge Begleitung mit
allen medizinischen Untersuchungen.
Zurzeit sieht alles gut aus.
Auch fürs Spielen
nimmt sich die Hebamme Zeit.
Arun, knapp eineinhalb Jahre alt,
leidet seit seiner Geburt an der
Darmerkrankung Morbus Hirschsprung.
Die Nervenzellen im Darm
weisen eine Fehlbildung auf.
Schon acht Operationen
hat er hinter sich.
Noch ein Kind mit Behinderung
wäre eine grosse Herausforderung
für die Familie.
Es besteht ein erhöhtes Risiko -
etwa 5 % -
dass es wieder
ein Hirschsprung-Kind gibt.
Aber diesmal gäbe es
gewiss kein so grosses ...
... Theater.
Wenn irgendetwas mit der Verdauung
nicht in Ordnung ist,
wissen wir sofort,
worauf wir achten müssen.
Im Kinderspital kennt man uns nun.
Dann gäbe es gewiss nicht so viele
Operationen, Zweifel und Fragen.
Dann wissen wir,
dass es wieder das sein muss.
Aber ich habe überhaupt nicht den
Eindruck, dass etwas nicht stimmt.
Rebecca und Stefan nehmen es,
wie es kommt.
Gelassen, wie das meiste.
Damit sie es nicht klaut. Danke.
Kannst du nicht so viel
mit der Schwangerschaft anfangen?
Ich mag sie lieber, wenn sie
nicht schwanger ist.- Wieso?
Du bist schön
und es ist schön, dass
du schwanger bist, aber du bist ...
* Karin und Stefan lachen. *
Beende den Satz.
Du bist erträglicher,
wenn du nicht schwanger bist.
Das hörte ich noch nie.
- Nein?
Ist das neu?
- Von dir hörte ich es noch nicht.
Wirklich? Wieso?
Ist sie etwas empfindsamer?
Schwieriger.
Ich hörte,
ich sei etwas anstrengend.
Oder sind es alle anderen?
* Lachen *
Ich hatte in letzter Zeit
etwas Probleme mit der Hitze
und jammerte vielleicht
ein bisschen viel.
Aber das darf ich jetzt auch.
Dieses Recht habe ich.
Es ist anstrengend bei dieser Hitze
mit den beiden Kindern.
Baby, beweg dich mal.
Ich habe gerade
etwas Schönes gesehen,
das gut zu den geplanten ...
... Geburtskärtchen passt.
Das muss ich sofort filmen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Dieses ehemalige Bauernhaus
soll ihr neues Zuhause werden.
Es liegt in Brunnadern, im Neckertal.
Bis es so weit ist,
gibt es noch viel zu tun.
Der 32-jährige Stefan
ist gelernter Schreiner
und macht den Umbau selbst.
Seit sieben Jahren
ist er nun schon dran.
Er kann den Einzug kaum erwarten.
Es ist viel einfacher, wenn man
den Garten direkt vor dem Haus hat.
Dann kann man einfach rausgehen,
muss nicht immer alles einpacken
und 10 oder 15 Min. gehen, bis man
im nächsten Park oder im Wald ist.
Man kann einfach rausgehen
und wenn etwas ist,
ist man direkt beim Haus.
Das wäre sicher einfacher.
Ich freue mich schon.
- Geht's, Jeshua?
Die Schule und der Kindergarten
sind in der Nähe.
Das ist natürlich
auch nicht schlecht.
Wollen wir ihnen zeigen, wo wir
hoffentlich bald wohnen werden?
* Stefan lacht. *
Im Frühling, nicht wahr?
Wenn es fertig ist.
- Vor Jeshuas Einschulung.
Jetzt kommt er in die Spielgruppe,
nächstes Jahr in den Kindergarten.
Das gilt als Einschulung.
Nächstes Jahr
müssen wir also hier wohnen.
Es ist halt noch eine Baustelle.
Hier ist unsere Wohnung.
Hier kommt die Küche hin,
die wir bereits bestellt haben.
(Jeshua) Können wir hier hochgehen?
- Du kannst hochspringen.
Willst du hochklettern?
- Wo?- Hier.
Jetzt ist es noch etwas schwierig.
Oh, gibt es etwas auszumessen?
Hier in Brunnadern gibt es Platz.
Ihr Hausteil ist fast dreimal grösser
als die kleine Wohnung in St. Gallen.
Ich kann es kaum erwarten.
In der Wohnung ist es so eng,
alles ist so klein,
die Küche geht mir auf die Nerven
und es gibt nirgends Stauraum.
* Seufzen *
Die Kinder werden
in unserer Wohnung,
die sich durch den Erker
nicht runterkühlen lässt,
auch etwas gaga
und schreien die ganze Zeit.
Dann bin ich abends ...
* Seufzen *
... fertig mit den Nerven.
Dann ...
... lasse ich meinen Frust
manchmal schon etwas an ihm aus.
(Jeshua) Schau mal.
Aber er verzeiht mir wieder.
Ich bin nicht mehr
so lange schwanger.- Ja.
Noch gut zweieinhalb Monate -
dann soll das Baby zur Welt kommen.
Rebecca ist
gelernte Fachangestellte Gesundheit.
Ihre Erfahrung hilft
im Umgang mit dem kranken Arun.
Ich gebe Arun nun noch etwas Wasser,
weil es so heiss ist.
Da er nicht so viel trinkt,
mache ich das über die Magensonde.
* Arun plappert. *
Er merkt wahrscheinlich,
dass etwas kühles Wasser ...
Bei diesen Temperaturen ist es
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so kühl,
aber er wird merken, dass es
an seiner Nase etwas kühler wird.
Die Sommerhitze macht nicht nur
dem kleinen Sohn zu schaffen.
Ist dir heiss?
- Ja, extrem heiss. Unerträglich.
Eigentlich ist es ja schön,
aber ich spüre die Hitze
zurzeit viel intensiver.
Das ist nicht
die aufwendige Version.
Eigentlich könnte man
noch spezielle Salben ...
... verwenden.
Arun hat wegen
seiner Darmerkrankung ein Stoma,
einen künstlichen Darmausgang.
Der Darminhalt wird über die Bauch-
decke in einen Sack ausgeschieden.
Das müssen wir nun
nicht mehr so lange machen.
Wir haben bereits
einen Operationstermin.
Das kommt auch noch hinzu.
Das ist noch vor der Geburt.
Das Stoma soll noch vor der Geburt
des Geschwisterchens operiert werden.
Dann benötigt Arun keinen Sack mehr
am Bauch, sondern nur noch Windeln.
Du kannst es sauber machen.
* Jeshua plappert. *
Es wird anstrengend werden.
Aber das wird es so oder so -
egal ob wir den Stoma-Sack wechseln
oder ob wir ihn
20-mal wickeln müssen.
Es wird einfach anstrengend.
Dann kommt noch ein Baby hinzu,
das vielleicht alle 2-3 Std.
gestillt und gewickelt werden muss.
Das bedeutet wenig Schlaf.
Aber wir schlafen
ja schon jetzt nicht.
Wir müssen den Stoma-Sack jede Nacht
fünf- bis siebenmal entleeren.
Es ist ... Ich weiss auch nicht.
Es ist halt einfach so.
Wir schlafen nicht.
Zurzeit begegnen mir
überall Schmetterlinge.
Da ich das
ein schönes Zeichen finde,
soll auf der Geburtsanzeige diesmal
ein Schmetterling abgebildet sein.
Davon muss ich nun noch etwa ...
... 25 machen.
Dann sind es etwa 70. Wenn hier
noch der Schmetterling liegt ...
In der 30. Schwangerschaftswoche
geht es auf Anraten der Hebamme
zum Ultraschalltermin.
Anstatt den Lift wählt Rebecca
die Treppe - in den vierten Stock.
Mit zwei Kindern komme ich
ja nicht grossartig dazu,
Sport zu machen.
Daher nutze ich jede Gelegenheit.
Wenn ich oben bin, brauche ich
nicht mehr so viel zu reden,
weil ich dafür
zu sehr ausser Atem bin.
* Lachen *
Der ist gut.
(Ärztin) Frau Wullschleger.
- Guten Tag.
Wie geht's?
- Gut.
Der Bauch ist ganz schön gewachsen.
- Ja, nicht wahr?
Der Po ist oben.
Und hier sind die Füsschen.
Wird sich das wohl noch ändern?
Es kann sich theoretisch
noch bis zur Geburt drehen,
aber in der Regel
bleibt der Kopf unten.
Es würde genau richtig liegen.
Hier blicken wir auf seinen Nacken.
Und dort ist die Wirbelsäule.
Da unten ist das Gesicht. Es blickt
mit dem Gesicht nach unten.
Ich weiss natürlich, was es wird.
- Mhm.
Was denken Sie?
Ich dachte immer,
dass es ein Mädchen wird.
Und Sie?
Ich schliesse mich an.
* Lachen *
Okay.
- Wir haben ja schon zwei Jungen.
Da die Schwangerschaft etwas anders
war, tippe ich auf ein Mädchen.
Das denken die Frauen oft,
aber das muss
oftmals nichts heissen.
Aber lassen Sie sich überraschen.
Die Gewichtsangabe
ist nicht so genau.
Je fortgeschrittener
die Schwangerschaft,
desto unsicherer
die Gewichtsschätzungen.
Die Hebamme und Sie sollten darauf
achten, dass der Bauch wächst.- Ja.
Ob das Baby
eine Darmkrankheit hat wie Arun,
kann nicht zu 100 %
ausgeschlossen werden.
Gut.
So, Frau Wullschleger,
das Kind ist eher etwas zarter.
Das passt auch
zur Fruchtwassermenge.
Zartere Kinder haben immer
etwas weniger Fruchtwasser.
Die Plazentadurchblutung ist gut.
- Okay.
Vor der Geburt
sollte man aber auf jeden Fall
nochmals das Wachstum kontrollieren.
Sie sollten vor der Geburt nochmals
einen Ultraschall machen lassen.
Bislang sehe ich nichts, was gegen
eine Hausgeburt sprechen würde.
Gut.
Das Baby muss
nur schön weiterwachsen.- Mhm.
Bei einer Hausgeburt
möchte man natürlich vermeiden,
dass irgendwelche Risiken bestehen -
seien es mütterliche
oder kindliche Risiken.
Für mich wäre es wichtig,
dass der Geburtsort nicht so weit
vom nächsten Spital entfernt liegt.
Denn man weiss natürlich,
dass es unter der Geburt auch
unerwartete Probleme geben kann.
Diese kann es immer geben.
Das ist halt einfach so.
Man sollte aber wenigstens
die Möglichkeit haben,
relativ rasch
ein Spital aufzusuchen.
Die 36-jährige Rebecca
ist deshalb
sowohl im Spital St. Gallen
als auch in Herisau angemeldet.
Die Verantwortung für die Hausgeburt
und eine allfällige Verlegung
trägt die Hebamme.
Danke, gleichfalls. Auf Wiedersehen.
Auf Wiedersehen.
- Einen schönen Tag.
Mir bedeutet das Ultraschallbild
eigentlich wirklich nicht viel.
Ich sehe, wie der Bauch wächst,
und ich sehe das Baby,
wenn es zur Welt kommt.
Das möchte ich sehen
und nicht irgendwelche
seltsamen Ultraschallbilder.
Es ist schön, zu wissen,
dass es gesund ist, aber ...
Soweit gesund zumindest.
- Ja.
Ich weiss,
dass er sich aufs Kind freut,
auch wenn es
vielleicht nicht so wirkt.
Ehrlichkeit,
Verständnis füreinander -
doch was ist denn für sie Liebe?
Möchtest du zuerst etwas sagen?
- Ja ... Hm ...
Das ist schwierig.
- Liebe ist schwierig.
Also, Zusammenhalt,
Vertrauen und ...
... die nächste Stufe von Gernhaben.
Die nächste Stufe von Gernhaben, ja.
Fami...
Die grösste Liebe ist für mich,
dass wir gemeinsam
eine Familie haben.
Nachdem ...
... Jeshua zur Welt kam,
waren wir ...
... gemeinsam in Jeshua verliebt.
Unsere Liebe ist noch gewachsen.
Das finde ich so schön.
Es könnte schon
in sieben Wochen so weit sein.
Dann bin ich bei 37+0.
Ich habe schon
einige Dinge vorbereitet:
Vier bis fünf Lein- oder Frottee-
tücher, eine Plastikfolie
und Tücher, in denen wir das Baby
nach der Geburt einwickeln können.
Für die Snacks, das Wichtigste,
ist Stefan verantwortlich.
Für die Hebamme Karin Künzle steht
der letzte Besuch vor der Geburt an.
Rebecca ist in der 37. Woche.
Ab jetzt ist Karin Künzle
rund um die Uhr auf Abruf.
Dieses Zeug könnt ihr
ins Geburtszimmer bringen.
Wenn du einen Blasensprung hast,
könnt ihr die Binden
schon verwenden.
Die Unterlagenpackung
könnt ihr auch öffnen.
Da ich auf keine andere Geburt
warte, lasse ich meine Sachen hier.
Dann brauche ich sie
nicht hochzutragen.
Rebecca ist meine letzte Hausgeburt.
Das habe ich vor Kurzem bzw.
schon vor einer Weile entschieden.
Ich mache das schon
seit ein paar Jahren
und möchte nun
anderen Dingen in meinem Leben
etwas mehr Gewicht geben,
die sich mit der Hausgeburtshilfe
nicht so gut vereinbaren lassen.
Das wär's.
Wollen wir die Dinge
gleich in die Schublade legen?
Ich brauchte lange,
um diese Entscheidung zu fällen.
Die Hausgeburtshilfe ist für mich
eine extrem sinnvolle Geburtshilfe.
Ich lernte dabei wahnsinnig viel
übers Leben, über mich,
über die Frauen und übers Gebären.
Es ist absolut nicht vergleichbar
mit einer Geburt im Spital.
Die Hausgeburtshilfe
liegt mir daher sehr am Herzen
und es ist mir ein grosses Anliegen,
dass das für die Frauen
weiterhin möglich ist.
Aber ich persönlich
benötige zurzeit eine Pause.
Alles.
- Alles.
Brokkoli?
Nein, er ist noch heiss.
- Immer noch?
Ja. - Und wenn ich
nur ein bisschen nehme und puste?
Es ist immer noch heiss.
- Aha.
(Stefan) Dann machen wir
einen Salat. - Mhm.
(Stefan) Den kochen wir nicht.
Fleisch sucht man nicht nur
in der Spielküche vergebens.
Wir ernähren uns vegan.
Ich ernähre mich komplett vegan.
Stefan ernährt sich
zu Hause auch komplett vegan.
Arun ...
... wird auch noch vegan ernährt.
Jeshua nicht.
Er isst Käse und Quark.
Rebecca achtet darauf, dass sie
wichtige Vitamine und Spurenelemente
als Nahrungsergänzung zu sich nimmt
und sich regelmässig testen lässt.
Dennoch muss sie ihre Ernährungsweise
immer wieder verteidigen.
Als ich mit Arun schwanger war
und das erste Mal bei Karin war,
dachte ich: "Hoffentlich fragt sie
mich nicht nach der Ernährung,
sonst muss ich mich herausreden."
Seit ich stille, kann ich
keine Milchprodukte mehr essen,
weil ich mir vorstelle, dass
einer anderen Mutter - einer Kuh -
das Kind weggenommen wird,
nur damit ich Käse essen kann.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle, dass mir
mein Kind weggenommen würde,
nur weil man meine Milch will ...
Karin zeigte viel Verständnis.
Sie ernährte sich auch lange vegan
und ist zurzeit Vegetarierin.
Arun hat seit der letzten
erfolgreichen Operation
einen gesunden Appetit entwickelt.
Die Magensonde
kann bald entfernt werden.
Du bist
auch schon bald eine Hebamme.
Möchtest du Hebamme,
äh, Hebammer werden?- Nein?
Die letzte Operation
hat stattgefunden.
Es scheint alles in Ordnung zu sein.
Wir haben
neue Lebensqualität gewonnen.
Wir müssen den Sack
nicht mehr ankleben
und können ihn einfach nur wickeln.
Nun können ihn
auch die Grosseltern hüten,
was bisher nie möglich war.
Ich habe gerade
etwas sehr Wichtiges geschafft,
das ich vor der Geburt
noch erledigen musste.
Diesen Drachen
erhielt Jeshua zur Geburt
und diesen erhielt Arun.
Nun habe ich den Drachen
fürs Baby fertiggestellt.
Hello.
- Hallo.
So.
Danke.
Babykleider.
Stefan hatte ja eine sehr wichtige
Aufgabe - fast die wichtigste.
Snacks.
- (Lachend) Snacks.
Hier haben wir Chips,
Lebkuchenherzen ...
... Nüsse, Magenbrot ...
- (Erfreut) Magenbrot.
... Crunchy Nut, Dinkel-Schokokekse.
Mmh.
Danke, Snack-Master.
Ich stelle mir
die Geburt sehr schnell vor.- Ja.
Und dass ich diesmal zwei Kinder
in den Armen halte und dir zuschaue.
Wirklich? Ich stelle mir vor,
dass Jeshua unten reinblickt.
"Komm raus."
- "Baby, wie geht es dir?"
"Was machst du?"
Ja.
- Ja, etwa so.
Ja, ich ...
... stelle sie mir auch schnell vor.
- Mit vielen Snacks.
Ich schreibe jetzt:
"Hat regelmässige Wehen".
11. Oktober, morgens kurz vor 5 Uhr:
Rebecca ist mit Kontraktionen
aufgewacht und hat Karin informiert.
Ich könnte dir
auch einen Einlauf machen.
Ja, vielleicht.
- Hattest du schon mal einen?
Ich habe immer
diese Clyssie-Dinger verwendet.
Ein hoher Einlauf?
- Ja, wenn schon, denn schon.
Oh.
- Trinkt doch zuerst einen Tee.
Gibt das keine Schweinerei?
- Nein, nein.
Es ist nicht zwingend, Rebecca.
Wir können auch warten.
* Stöhnen, Lachen *
Du hast also keine richtigen Wehen?
Richtige Wehen ...
Doch, es sind richtige Wehen,
aber ich weiss nicht,
ob das die Geburt ist.
Bisher hatte ich zweimal einen
Blasensprung und erst danach Wehen.
"Wehen".- Aber die Wehen
sind nicht so stark und ...
Ich nehme einen Fencheltee.
Aber ich habe mich doch überwunden,
Karin anzurufen,
da sie regelmässig sind.
Bei Rebecca
ist es schwer einzuschätzen,
da sie quietschfidel ist
und mir noch einen Tee anbietet.
Das war letztes Mal schon so
und fünf Wehen später war Arun da.
Okay.
* Lachen *
Dass jemand noch so lacht wie sie,
ist nicht normal.
Hier könnte man es aufhängen.
- Ich glaube, Stefan macht das gut.
* Lachen *
Kannst du ihn drehen, damit ich
sehe, wie viel reinging?
Sehr gut.
Man lässt warmes Wasser in den Darm
fliessen. Das entleert den Darm.
Der Darm und die Gebärmutter,
die so nahe beieinander sind,
arbeiten gleichzeitig.
So kann man die Gebärmutter anregen
und im Becken
entsteht Platz fürs Kind.
Unterdessen ist es 6 Uhr.
Ob das Baby wirklich heute kommt?
Nach starken Wehen
sieht es nicht aus.
(Lachend)
Muss ich jetzt Schmerzen ...
Muss ich jetzt wirklich ...
* Lachen *
Stefan.
* Sie stöhnt. *
* Lachen *
Wir wissen es nicht, Rebecca.
Vielleicht sind es einfach Vorwehen.
Ja, vielleicht
ist es wirklich nichts.
Im gemeinsamen Schlafzimmer
ist Jeshua erwacht.
Rebecca legt Wert darauf, dass
die Kinder bei der Geburt dabei sind.
Jetzt spürt man ein Polster.
(Jeshua) Hallo, Baby.
Es wartet noch ein bisschen.
Was braucht das Baby wohl,
damit es rauskommt?
Hm, ich weiss es auch nicht.
Du weisst es auch nicht?
Hast du keine Idee?
Bohren, bohren, bohren.
Meinst du,
es kommt zum Bauchnabel raus?
* Lachen *
Ja ...
Ich sehe kein Blut.
D.h., dass es ...
Ich glaube, es fehlt
noch ein bisschen Hormon,
aber das Kind liegt extrem tief.
Ich verstehe,
dass du angerufen hast.
Es ist total schwierig,
zu wissen, wann man anrufen soll.
Eine Weile zu liegen,
ist sicher gut.- Okay.
Ja, Jeshua?
Wir brauchen ein paar Sofakissen.
Tatsächlich?
Welche Sofakissen?
* Klingeln des Handyweckers *
Jetzt müsste ich aufstehen.
Catchy 6.39 Uhr, cool, was?
Karin Künzle entscheidet sich,
in der Zwischenzeit
Wochenbettbesuche abzuhalten.
Sie rechnet nicht
mit einer baldigen Geburt.
Wir warten auf Christine.
Tschüss, Arun.
* Jeshua plappert. *
Macht es gut, bis dann.
- (Alle) Tschüss.
Obwohl es jederzeit losgehen kann,
lässt sich auch Rebecca
nicht aus der Ruhe bringen
und macht für alle erst mal Zmorge.
Die anderen beiden
kamen ja extrem schnell.
Aber es soll dann kommen,
wenn der Zeitpunkt stimmt.
Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Immerhin habe ich Wehen.
Das ist schon mal was.
War es wirklich ein Fehlalarm?
Die Snacks
stehen auf alle Fälle schon bereit.
(Jeshua) Tee im Kaffee.
- (Stefan) Teebeutel im Kaffee?
Ja.
- Also ein Kaffeebeutel?
Das Sitzen ist etwas unangenehm. Das
Baby ist schon ziemlich tief unten.
Ich spüre es schon.
Es ist am richtigen Ort.
Aber es geht mir gut.
Ich bin einfach müde.
Aber nachher lege ich mich hin.
Kurz vor 8 Uhr:
Rebecca gönnt sich eine Pause.
* Erleichtertes Seufzen *
Etwas Schlaf tut mir sehr gut.
(Jeshua) Ich schaue zu,
wie das Baby rauskommt.
Keine Stunde später geht es los.
Die Hebamme ist gerade noch
rechtzeitig zurückgekommen.
* Schmerzvolles Stöhnen *
* Herzgeräusche *
Hörst du etwas?
* Stöhnen *
Au! Au!
Au!
* Schreien *
Es tut so weh!
Ja!
Oh, Baby.
Oh, Baby, Baby.
Tipptopp, alles okay.
Genau, heb das Bein etwas hoch.
Gut.
Baby-Schatz.
* Das Baby schreit. *
* Rebecca weint. *
Jetzt ist das Baby rausgekommen.
- Oh, Baby.
* Rebecca weint. *
Mein Schatz.
Wir haben ein Baby bekommen.
* Das Baby weint. *
* Sanfte Klänge *
Jetzt ist das Baby da.
Es ist rausgekommen wie du.
* Das Baby weint. *
Oh, Schätzchen.
(Schluchzend)
Du bist wirklich ein Mädchen.
Jetzt haben wir noch ein Mädchen.
Daya Alia Nejä Karin Quarta
heisst die neue Erdenbürgerin.
Wir hatten alle recht.
Wir sagten, dass es ein Mädchen ist.
Ja, es ist da und es sagte:
"Ich will raus."
(Jeshua) Warum?
Es flüsterte
und wir hörten es nicht.
Du bist aber sanft.
Du machst das super.
Nun macht es ein Bläschen.
Welches Bläschen?
- Dieses hier.
Wie ein Seifenbläschen.
* Jeshua lacht. *
* Daya weint. *
(Flüsternd) Ja, ich verstehe dich.
(Jeshua) Karin?
- Ja?
Das Baby
hat schon Kacka gemacht.
Es wollte dir zeigen,
dass sein Darm in Ordnung ist.
Stefan, es hat schon Kacka gemacht.
- Es hat keinen Morbus Hirschsprung.
Es kommt schon ein bisschen Milch.
Sie trinkt.
- Gut.
Wow!
Oh, ich bin so glücklich.
Ich bin so glücklich.
Es ist
ein unglaublich starkes Gefühl.
Vorhin war ich wirklich müde,
aber ich glaube,
nun könnte ich Bäume ausreissen.
Es ist wirklich ...
Ich habe ein Kind zur Welt gebracht.
Das ist unglaublich.
Aus der Nabelschnur
ist alles Blut ausgeflossen,
erst jetzt wird sie durchgeschnitten.
Nun darf der grosse Bruder mithelfen,
die Schnur durchzuschneiden.
Gerade mal 1 % aller Babys
in der Schweiz
kommen in einem solch
familiären Umfeld auf die Welt.
Du darfst es hier halten.
Daya ist gut gewachsen,
3'190 g schwer.
Einmal das Bein ausstrecken.
Zeig mir mal, wie lang du bist.
Lang, lang, lang. Wow!
48 cm.
Für Karin ist es eine wunderschöne
letzte Hausgeburt gewesen.
Jetzt will sie sich neu orientieren,
um Job und Freizeit
besser vereinbaren zu können.
* Sanfte Klänge *
* Lachen *
Okay?
- Ja.
Kannst du aufstehen?
Ist dein Kreislauf okay?- Ja.
Drei Kinder
hat die junge Familie nun.
Wenn es nach dem Vater geht,
dürfen es 15 werden.
Aber jetzt wird erst mal
das Wochenbett genossen.
Hallo, Baby.
Oh, schön.
So schön. Kommst du
auch ein bisschen zu mir?
Hier ist ein Barthaar von Papa.
Hast du geträumt, Daya?
(Flüsternd) Du bist so süss.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022